The phrase quantum is another one that's fraught with woo indeed.
Right.
And some people,
uh,
like Deepak Chopra and the like,
they love to use that word because as soon as you use that word,
you can kind of get away with almost anything afterwards.
Yes.
I have to say I have quantum mechanics is a strange thing.
And I saw the blame me for certain things.
I don't want to be unfair here.
I'm not saying that's,
I blame it.
It gives some people got the impression,
okay.
The fact your theory doesn't make any sense.
That's nothing against it said crazy things.
Quantum mechanics is crazy.
So we wanted to except some other crazy theory.
Of course quantum mechanics has the virtue of that.
It does agree with an awful lot of experiments and it gives you a huge insight
since the things that that one didn't have before.
So just the fact that it's crazy isn't,
isn't enough to,
to make,
to make it something you should study seriously.
Well,
um,
well it's very,
very difficult to understand even for people who study it.
Yes,
indeed.
So for someone like myself,
I'm trying to pay attention to this without devoting my entire life to it and it
gets,
it's becomes a big problem because there's,
yeah.
Yeah,
I did too.
I I in one of my books I tried to explain there are actually two mysteries in
quantum mechanics and they get muddled.
One of them is the whole subject is pretty crazy.
Yes,
but it's coherent and it makes sense and if you study it properly and you say,
okay,
that makes sense.
And this includes things like non local effects where you can have two things
now they know eating thousands of kilometers apart and you can see these quantum
entanglement effects.
So they're are still in some sense connected with each other even though they're
that far apart,
which is pretty amazing.
That's baffling.
It's baffling.
But that's part of the comprehensive or part of course it's muddied up because
there's the other part which has to do with this collapse of the wave function
and standard quantum mechanics really doesn't make sense.
But people get them muddled in my year you think because this doesn't make sense
and that does mean well,
it's all a bit crazy and so anything crazy is,
is is up for grabs.
But it seems to me that quantum mechanics,
the things which are crazy and they do hang together under the theory works and
you understand that that's fine,
but the things which involve the collapse of the wave function,
that's not fine because we don't have the right theory yet.
That's why it doesn't make logical sense because it's not the right theory yet.
That's my view.
I mean I'm a minority and saying this,
most people who study the foundations of quantum mechanics say,
well,
we haven't got the right interpretation right yet.
We have to think when it means and so on.
They don't think,
well,
maybe it's not quite right.
Maybe there's something when these effects get big enough,
something else comes in and we,
we need a new insights and new theory.
So that's what I think
now in something like super position where something be both still and in motion
at the same time.
As soon as you say that.
Yeah,
to the common person like myself,
my brain glazes over and uh,
my eyebrows raised up and I go,
okay,
what does,
and then you're talking about entanglement things hundreds of thousands of
kilometers apart that are somehow or another interacting with each other in a
way that we don't totally understand or we don't have a theory that absolutely
explains in a concrete way,
but it does as long as you don't get to the measurement,
the measurement entanglement pot is pretty well understood.
But the measurement,
the measurement part is not busy.
The puzzles about the entanglement is when you come to the measurement,
uh,
he make a measurement over here and the management over there and they can be,
well now I thought I wasn't going to me,
she's apart.
The record was only 143 or something a little while ago.
Wow.
It's a,
it's a long time,
a long distance,
but there's hardly any movement of material.
So the thing that you see in the scheme I have,
which involves the collapse of the wave function involves certain amount of
displacement and mass.
Now,
if it's just photons that's light,
and these experiments tend to be just light,
then there's no mass displacement in the state.
And so sure,
what quantum mechanics says is fine by me.
Okay.
It's hard to get your mind around,
and I certainly agree with that,
but it's logical.
What's not logical comes apart.
But when you worry about the measurement issue and the collapse of the wave
function,
and poor old Schrodinger was very upset by this,
quite right.
Yes.